It's nearly impossible for modern directors
to keep references to their favorite movies
or directors out of their own films, with
easter eggs, props, and even lines of dialogue
being planted as an homage.
But sometimes, it's the sounds of the movie
that show where the real influences lie - even
if they're nearly impossible to catch.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Movies That Stole
Their Sounds From Other Films.
Avatar
James Cameron's alien epic was years in the
making, with the wildlife of Pandora one of
the most memorable parts.
The director originally dreamed up the panther-like
Xanator with a script note saying it could
even beat a T-Rex - so it's no surprise that
it sounds just like the version seen in Jurassic
Park.
It's not the only dinosaur sound lifted for
Avatar, either, since the Direhorse lets out
snort and barks that are impossible to miss
for fans of Spielberg's dinosaur adventure.
Lord of the Rings: The Two Towers
You know it, and you've heard it, even if
you don't know what it's called.
Easily the most famous reused movie sound
effect of all time, The "Wilhelm Scream" made
its first appearance in Distant Drums.
When the scream was used in Star Wars and
Indiana Jones, it became an inside joke for
engineers everywhere - and The Lord of The
Rings featured A LOT of them.
Once you notice it, no blockbuster will ever
be the same - and it's so overused, there
are plenty of movie fans who'd probably be
happy to see it retired.
Jaws
Most movie fans will tell you that it was
the movie Jaws that made Steven Spielberg
a Hollywood hit, but his FIRST movie about
a monstrous beast chasing an everyday man
taught him all he needed to know about suspense
and terror.
Duel swapped out the shark for a murderous
fuel truck driver, but it also ended with
the truck defeated, and a monster's roar added
to its death for added effect.
When it came to the death scene in Jaws, Spielberg
made sure to include the same sample as "a
thank you" to the movie that started his career.
Ant-Man
When Disney acquired the rights to the Star
Wars universe, fans didn't expect to see the
results in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
But the story of the smallest Avengers featured
an easter egg that's easy to miss.
When Ant-Man villain Yellowjacket finally
suits up, it's his laser cannons, not shrinking,
that poses the biggest threat.
But if those cannons sound familiar, it's
probably the sound of the Imperial AT-AT walker's
main cannon from The Empire Strikes Back buried
within them.
Star Trek
J.J. Abrams gave a surprisingly believable
vision of the future in his Star Trek reboot,
but the sounds used weren't so original.
Audiences might have missed the fact that
Kirk's motorcycle was riding on spoke-less
wheels.
But the motorcycle's sound was an even more
subtle detail.
Especially when you realize you're hearing
a remixed version of the sound of a flying
car in The Jetsons cartoon universe.
Blade Runner
The links between both of Ridley Scott's sci-fi
dramas have been studied by fans since they
first released, with evidence mounting that
Blade Runner and Alien take place in the same
universe.
The sounds support the idea, too.
A low humming noise is audible under most
of Alien's scenes set in the spaceship's crew
quarters, with a more pronounced effect planned
for the ship's medbay.
That specific sound wasn't used in the finished
movie, but the sound editor placed it in Blade
Runner, making Deckard's apartment sound almost
identical to the Nostromo.
Wreck-it Ralph
It isn't just classic games that are paid
tribute to in this story of a villain-turned-hero,
since the movie shares a sound designer and
mixer with some serious blockbusters.
One of those films is Terminator 2: Judgment
Day, which explains why Calhoun's gun is clearly
making the exact same sound as the laser weapons
fired by the T-800's in the movie's opening
scene.
On top of that, the sound effect made when
opening the vault in Cyberdyne Systems' lab
is also translated into the animated movie,
when King Candy hacks into the code of Sugar
Rush.
It turns out it wasn't just video game cameos
fans had to watch out for.
Star Trek Into Darkness
If there's one director J.J. Abrams has pointed
to more than any other, it's Steven Spielberg,
whose vision of the future seen in Minority
Report probably played a role in creating
the same near future of the rebooted Star
Trek.
The sci-fi story of cops who stop crimes before
they're committed even got a shout-out when
Khan crashes his ship into San Francisco.
Listen closely to the alarms and sirens playing
as Khan starts to flee the scene - apparently,
the Pre-Crime cops were the first to respond.
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
This prequel to Raiders of the Lost Ark dealt
with plenty of dark magic, including human
sacrifice by way of a burning hot lava pit.
When Indy's new leading lady is the next to
be sacrificed, she gets a front row seat to
the opening of the pit.
But listen closely, and you'll hear a familiar
sound.
It isn't just the stone doors being opened,
but the unforgettable sound of a lightsaber
igniting.Specifically, Darth Vader's saber
in The Empire Strikes Back.
Man of Steel
Zack Snyder's take on Superman was a very
different one from what fans were used to,
but the sound team made sure to include one
major easter egg for fans of the original
George Reeves version.
When filming The Adventures of Superman in
the 1950s, short scenes of Reeves flying across
a sky blue backdrop were used, with a sound
of rushing wind to sell the scene.
Special effects have come a long way, but
that same wind sound effect is included when
the new Man of Steel takes flight.
It's hard to hear, but the sound designers
confirm it's there for those who know what
they're looking for.
Those are the best sound effects borrowed
or hidden by blockbuster directors that we
could find, but which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!